are you talking to me or him  that's actually a good question i think  both of us are going to have a different  answer i think i'm going to say no  because i don't think i've ever been  caught you might have an answer of you  might have walked in on it and i didn't  see you here's what's even worse it  wasn't me it was your mom  she walked into the bedroom ghost white  shut the door and she goes i'm never  going in his room again  and right away i was like oh he was  jerking off huh she was like how'd you  know i'm like that's the only thing that  would elicit  that  yeah well that's a bummer i've never  caught him jerking off  uh but my wife has and um sorry yeah  i'm not that's funny  i like it